(groaning)
- It tastes like cold barf.
(upbeat instrumental music)
I love juicy buffalo wings.
I could dip my fries in the sauce.
It's delicious.
- I love buffalo sauce on
pretty much everything.
- I don't think there are many people
who don't like buffalo chicken.
- I'm not really a big buffalo
chicken guy in general.
I know a lot of people would be ashamed
to hear me say that.
- A milkshake is just one
of the best things on earth.
- I like milkshakes, they
can be a little much.
- Vanilla, I know it sounds plain,
but like a vanilla bean milkshake,
kind of plain, that's
really, that's my jam.
- I like it so much that even though
I'm lactose intolerant I'll
still drink a milkshake.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- It's a nice color.
It's not un-appetizing.
- The chicken is actually the one thing
that's actually kind of
helping it a little bit
because it's the one thing that looks like
a normal piece of food.
- The blue cheese chunks
are kind of gross looking.
(gagging)
- Worst thing I've tried on BuzzFeed.
- The after taste is
really, it's something.
- The feeling is like if
someone lugeyed in their mouth
and spit it down your throat.
- It becomes more tolerable
as you work through it.
It's kind of like drinking ketchup.
- I feel like this could be a good base
for like a Bloody Mary situation
because it's already got
that like Worcestershire
kind of spiciness.
I think with some vodka
and some more vodka
it would be pretty good.
- It's inconsistent,
it's not even the same.
Like you drink it and it tastes bad
and then you drink another sip
and it tastes bad in a different way.
- It's like if you freeze
people's like sweat
after the gym and then just put it
and made it into a Popsicle.
- Like if somebody offered me some money,
not a lot of money, like
a decent amount of money,
I would down like a couple of these.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- It has the consistency of like diarrhea.
You know, like, ugh, ugh.
- It doesn't taste enough
like buffalo sauce for me.
I would have really preferred it
to be straight buffalo sauce.
- Next time I have a milkshake,
I'm definitely going to think
about this a little bit.
Like I'm going to have it
and I'm going to be like,
is this going to taste like blue cheese?
- Chicken and milk already
sounds bad together,
but it didn't even taste
bad in the way I thought
it would taste.
It tasted worst.
It surprised me.
Excuse me.
See, it's already coming back up.
It's already coming back.